hi this is pressure Locker in this video
we're going to discuss a game theory
puzzle called the race 2:15 here are the
rules to the game there are nine cards
numbered one two nine two players Alice
and Bob take turns picking up cards so
what that means is that Alice will pick
up the first card then Bob will pick up
any of the remaining cards then Alice
will pick one of the remaining cards and
so on the first player to collect a set
of three cards that add up to fifteen
wins the game the question is can Alice
who goes first guarantee a win I want
you to think about this game give it a
try and see if you can solve it when
you're ready keep watching for the
solution to the game so the difficult
part is trying to figure out the sets of
three numbers that add up to 15 the
trick is to use a 3x3 Magic Square in a
Magic Square every row column and
diagonal will have the same sum of 15 so
I could just write out the Magic Square
with the numbers 1 through 9 but I'm
going to show you how you can generate
this it's a method called the up right
or down method it starts out by writing
a 1 in the middle of the top row then
what you want to do is go up and to the
right to get the next number so here we
go up into the right and we need to wrap
around so this is where we write the
number 2 to get the next number we go up
into the right again we're going to need
to wrap around and this is where we
write 3 we again go up into the right
but this time we're blocked because this
Square already has one so when we're
blocked we go down so that's where we
write a 4 and we're going to keep on
applying this rule of going up into the
right to write the next number and
continue to fill out the square so in
the center square we have a 5
in the upper right hand corner we have a
six now we're going to try and go up
into the right we're going to need to
wrap this around where once again
blocked so we need to go down from where
the six is
that's where seven will be and we
continue filling it out we'll figure out
where the eight is by going up into the
right and the nine will also be up into
the right of eight as you get a few of
these in you can also fill them out just
by knowing that the sum of each row or
diagonal or column will be 15 so now we
have a Magic Square where every row and
column and diagonal sums up to 15 and
those are the only sets of three numbers
that add up to 15 so let's try and solve
the game so what we'll do is we'll
imagine when Alice picks a number we'll
visualize it on this 3x3 grid and we'll
mark her spot with an X so let's say she
picked 2/5 we put an X in the center
whichever number Bob picks if he picks
an 8 we'll put an O in that square so
having a sum of 15 means getting a three
in a row because the only way to get 15
is to have one of the rows columns or
diagonal and that's the insight this
game is exactly like tic-tac-toe
so wherever Alice goes and Bob's go
we're alternately picking X as a No both
players trying to get three in a row
since tic-tac-toe ends in a draw this
game also ends in a draw did you solve
the puzzle
I hope you liked this video please
subscribe to my channel you can support
me on patreon for exclusive rewards
catch me on my blog mynheer decisions on
Twitter at pressure Walker and you can
get my books listed on my website